Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
black panther wakanda forever video all about
how Kang created and is creating X-Men mutant
characters inside the MCU because of what
he's doing so there's a bunch of Easter eggs and
connections to break down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I know a lot of you also have questions
about Marvel's new X-Men movie that they're also
working on in the background all dressed at it too
and careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
movie yet during the movie we learned that Namor
is a genuine mutant they don't play the X-Men the
Animated Series theme music like they did during
Patrick Stewart's Professor X scene in Doctor
Strange Multiverse sub Madness or the Miss Marvel
finale when they revealed that she was a mutant
too like they really wanted to be on the nose
in those cases Neymar is just the next biggest
example of a mutant that's been inside the MCU
this whole time that we're just learning about now
so a big part of the movie is also explaining what
created mutants in the MCU in his case because
there are a number of different ways that mutants
were created like there's no one single way and
also why we're just learning about him now after
all these Marvel movies since the beginning of
phase one for Namor the answers that he's been
hiding himself and his people this whole time and
preventing knowledge of their race from spreading
by basically killing anyone who learned about them
for the past 500 years and until they introduce
a version of Apocalypse or Celine from the comics
in the 616 Universe Namor is currently the oldest
mutant that's also meant to be an Easter egg
for Namor in the comics being referred to as
the first mutant like literally they call him the
first mutant because in the real life history of
comics he was the first character to be called
a mutant before the X-Men were created in the
1960s but for example Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
was born in the early 1800s a little under 200
years ago also important to note that just because
we're seeing mutants coming from the MCU recently
they've been hiding out they've been around this
whole time we're also seeing them come from the
Multiverse from other universes because we're
in the middle of the Multiverse Saga some of
the other mutants core X-Men characters will come
from other universes like the fox Marvel Universe
in the case of Deadpool and Wolverine in Deadpool
3. I just did a big video about that because we
learned that Mobius and the TVA from the Loki
series are going to be big parts of that movie
I'll add a link for that at the end of this in the
description below Deadpool kills the fox Marvel
Universe mcavoyer Stewart these timelines are so
confusing but inside the MCU there are a couple
different things that created mutants or led to
the creation of mutants the reason Neymar was
born a mutant was because his mother ingested the
heart-shaped herb when she was pregnant with him
t'challa's father King tachaka and t'challa both
had the wakanan version of the heart-shaped Herb
in their systems when they father children so I
know a lot of you are asking now does that mean
the baby Azari t'challa in the post-credits scene
is a mutant now too why wasn't t'challa himself
born a mutant the answer to that is that mutants
are kind of like a genetic dice roll probability
kind of thing like just because your parents might
be mutants or because your mother might ingest a
heart-shaped herb when she's pregnant with you
doesn't guarantee that you're going to be born
a mutant we're getting new episodes of X-Men
the Animated Series on Disney plus next year
really good example that during that series is
Greydon Creed one of the main major antagonists
of the series he's the son of both Sabretooth and
Mystique he was born without any powers it's just
a way to explain how t'challa was not born with
powers even though his father had the heart-shaped
Herb in his system t'challa's son could still
be a mutant in the comics like we just saw his
character the future is wide open for him they can
do whatever they want to with that character and
it will make sense Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
are another big examples they were born mutants in
the MCU Scarlet Witch's children Billy and Tommy
are also mutants as well in their case as is the
case with most of the other mutants core X-Men
characters in general is the X Gene like that's
the other big deciding factor because there are
characters who are biologically altered on the
genetic level later in life like Spider-Man The
Hulk Maria Rambeau and they're not mutants they're
called mutates when stuff like that happens to
you like when Spider-Man got the spider bite or
Hulk was altered by the gamma experiments they
were called mutates not mutants the whole idea
with the x-gene is that it's sort of like the X
Factor so to speak talk about X-Men Easter eggs
where a lot of people are born with it and when
it expresses when you're born that's when you
become a mutant like just because you have the
X Gene doesn't guarantee that you're going to be
born with powers really good example of this
is the Miss Marvel character because she's a
mutant in the MCU we just learned something
different in your genes like like a mutation
she comes from a race of alternate Dimension
beings called Jinn and not all the other people
in her race are like her they explained that
because her parents conceived her inside the
alternate dimension of the MCU that's why she
was born with the X Gene and it was wearing
the band with the cosmic energy that activated her
x-gene that expressed her mutant abilities talking
more about the giant Stone Celestial in the Indian
Ocean a little while ago Marvel actually explained
the origin of the x-gene was from temit the
celestial that was growing inside planet Earth
basically it's Cosmic Celestial blood leached
into the soil and kind of like the vibranium
tainted the soil creating the heart-shaped herb
the same thing happened across planet Earth and
it slowly mutated everyone's DNA creating the
X Gene and throughout history major events have
happened that have caused people's ex genes to
express a long time ago we also theorized that
Thanos in Iron Man the Hulk everyone snapping The
Infinity Gauntlet so many times on planet Earth in
the MCU will cause a bunch of people's ex genes
to express and that's how they would explain a
lot of mutants just suddenly showing up out of
nowhere the difference with Miss Marvel's band
sort of tracing this back to the movies that are
coming up is it the writing on her band seems very
similar to the writing the markings on shangshi's
10 rings of power which seems very similar to the
writing on Kang's rings on his time travel Quantum
device in the Ant-Man 3 quantumania trailer so it
kind of seems like Kang might also be low level
responsible for the x-gen and mutants in the
MCU in some way and I think they'll pay that
off during Avengers 5 and Avengers six secret
words but name Ward's backstory Miss Marvel's
backstory is just another way to explain how
something big happens to express their X Gene so
even though there's a lot of different things that
are creating mutants in the MCU if you want to
point to like a single commonality like the one
thing in common that all these different mutants
have is probably going to be Kang Marvel's also
never fully explained where vibranium came from
only that at some point at the beginning of time
like during the Big Bang vibranium exploded Across
the Universe in a bunch of meteorites deposited it
all across the universe so early theory on
that is that King will also be tied to that
as well playing the Agatha all along theme music
everybody asking where vibranium came from where
mutants came from pointed to Kang it was Kang all
along I know a lot of you are asking about storm
now because she has such a deep connection with
the Black Panther character in the comics and
obviously we're going to see a version of storm
show up in the MCU eventually in the comic she's
born the princess of her tribe she's part of this
line of priestesses they're actually located very
close to wakanda because of all the wars in the
conflict she winds up growing up on the streets
of Egypt though but later in life gets married
to black panther they're both royalty they're
both super powerful on political and just
biological power levels storm is actually an
Omega Level mutant like one of the most powerful
types of mutants you could possibly be she can
control the weather yes but that's mostly because
of the way she can control Earth's electromagnetic
field Magneto can also tap into and control the
Earth's magnetic field but his powers are way
different what they might be doing in the movies
now because of the way they change the plot the
Black Panther what kind of ever post credit
scene is because they've already changed to
Chala Black Panther's backstory so much already
he is the child with Nakia they might eventually
age t'challa's son up also named t'challa and
when he becomes the next Black Panther then
he'll be the Black Panther to have a relationship
with the new MCU version of storm which is also
probably one of the reasons why they waited so
long to introduce a version of storm like nope
not yet we're not ready t'challa's son still a
little kid we don't need a version of storm yet
till he's a little bit older it's another way to
explain why you haven't seen like a thousand X-Men
show up in the MCU during Marvel phase 4. also
they are bringing back some Multiverse versions
like really good example is Halle Berry's storm
in secret War she'll probably have some fun Cameo
scene but I don't think she's gonna permanently
be the MCU version of storm going forward like
they'll introduce a brand new young version of
the character the only ones that I think are
safe from recasting in the near future at least
are Hugh Jackman's Wolverine Patrick Stewart's
Professor X and obviously Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
some of those actors will just continue to be the
main versions of those characters for a long time
but eventually some of the other X-Men characters
will be recast versions in talking about the brand
new X-Men movie that Marvel is working on inside
the MCU is still going to be a little while before
that actually happens like we have to actually see
a couple more X-Men characters show up before
they can actually put them on a team together
Kevin feige has said that he's introducing X-Men
characters through Marvel Phase 5 movies in Disney
plus series like one at a time all over the place
it sounds like Marvel's first big solo X-Men movie
like where they actually come together as a team
might not happen until after Secret Wars there's
been a lot of theories online about there being
some behind the scenes contractual issues with
them doing a solo X-Men movie really quickly and
that's why they're waiting so long that could be
the case but part of the reason is that a lot
of the plans that Kevin feige made for Marvel
phase 4 for example started way before they bought
Fox and got all the Marvel characters back Marvel
typically plans their movies and starts signing
contracts about five years in advance so a lot
of the contracts for a lot of these movies and the
way things work worked out got planned long before
the deal for the fox Marvel characters actually
closed so a lot of the movies that they released
during Marvel phase 4 actually started production
long before the deal closed that's the real reason
why you didn't see X-Men flying all over the place
starting in 2020 like right after the deal closed
when we do get the new X-Men episodes at the
end of next year I will be doing full videos
for all those just like I do for all the other
Marvel Disney plus series but if you do have any
more X-Men mutant questions after black panther
wakanda forever just post them in the comments
below everyone click here for my full post credit
scene video and click here for my new Deadpool
3 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!